Moffat: I'm Alex Moffat,
the chief engineer
for Lombardi Blueprint,
and I'm gonna show you
Blueprint,
an app that we built
with Google Web Toolkit.
So Blueprint is a business
process mapping tool
for business users
to collaboratively describe
their processes,
and try
and get agreement
about what
the processes actually are.
So the tool--what they'd
be using instead of Blueprint
is probably PowerPoint
or Visio.
You can see here
in the app
that on the left-hand side
we have an outline
of the process,
and on the right-hand side,
we have sort of a map view.
I can, uh, enter items
into the outline.
And then I can do
some drag and drop.
We also have, um,
a diagram view,
which looks a lot more
like Visio.
I can switch to that now.
Now the diagram
actually does
automated, uh, layout
of the boxes
and routing
of the lines.
And all of this is happening
on the client in JavaScript,
which is pretty remarkable.
Everything that
you're seeing here is done--
is executing
in an ordinary browser
in JavaScript.
There's no Flash or other
client-side plugins required.
And really, that's the benefit
that we get
from Google Web Toolkit.
We don't have to worry
about all of the browser quirks
that you fight with when
you're writing pure JavaScript.
We just write in a language
that we like to use,
and they take care of all
the difficult bits for us.